To summarize, if host A and
host B want to securely communicate,
here is the typical IPSec workflow.
Suppose this is the first
time that A sends data to B,
then according to policy
requires protection.
The router or gateway of A's network and
the router of B's network
then use the IKE protocol to
first negotiate the IKE SA.
And then use that IKE SA
to negotiate the IPSec SAs.
Then an IPSec tunnel can be
created between the routers and
the traffic from A to B is
protected by the tunnel.
For example,
the packet data can be encrypted and
optionally the head of information
including the source IP address
as well as the packet data
can be authenticated.
When A terminates the connection to B,
the IPSec tunnel between the two
routers also terminates.